[Music]
jumanji 3 what we saw it coming we we
knew this would happen especially
because they denounced it and they said
they were done filming guys we're gonna
watch this trailer I'm excited to check
it out the last one was a nice surprise
before we go into that Ridge John tell
them about the ridge that's right the
ridge wallet as a matter of fact their
flagship product the ridge makes these
awesome minimalist metal plated wallets
I fit easily in a front pocket a breast
pocket anywhere you like they keep your
stuff in order but with style and that
minimalist Sensibility so you can
declutter yourself they also make these
awesome weatherproof bags power banks
charging cables knives all kinds of
stuff so head over to Ridge dot-com
slash reject nation use our special
promo code reject nation to save
yourself ten percent and you get free
worldwide shipping grab yourself
something nice people don't use the
needle drops users use ours get rid of
your bulky ass wallet and join the
minimalist revolution now let's get into
this Thank You rich for sponsoring this
video
it looks like Jumanji
[Music]
Danny DeVito first got together it's
gonna fix it by Anthony this is a Martha
and Bethany this is very party more than
to any cooler
No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is back oh wow that was it that was
a nice surprise I thought I was gonna
turn into another one of those trailers
or like you know the stories of I can't
believe we're back here a night like a
hangover part - yeah we're doing this
again what's the same thing uh who fixed
the game yeah I think that's a really
refreshing way to bring back be original
like popular cast members yeah yeah but
then infused them with a new kind of
personality and uh fresh jokes I got
excited having them in there but like
they have distinct personalities but
they have like Kevin Hart riffing on it
Wayne Johnson or not it's funny because
like yeah they first they were riffing
on the really young personalities and
there's really a whole personality yeah
and again that's really that's a really
funny way to make it fresh even with
Jack Black being the different character
- yeah I think that's a that's a great
call well and I feel like it for the
future of this as a franchise because
you know they want to keep these going I
feel like that opens us up to a whole
lot of other possibilities because I
don't know what other game characters
are gonna get but yeah seeing them get
the same ensemble but having them play
completely different mannerisms and
completely different types makes this
all the more fun and I feel like you
know if you wanted to make a part three
I mean a part 4 part 5 or whatever you
know you could just keep that going and
always have them doing different you
know alter-ego true oh I wonder why he
brought the game back what's that
actor's name again ala Great Wolf
Alex wolf yeah from hereditary yeah -
knowing that
strong work bringing it over to here
yeah man he goes away from Tony
Colette's to live with his brother hey
bye Danny DeVito's same universe he
wants to get away we can get colin hanks
back though I know what in the trailer I
didn't see any Hanks in this trailer
although we did see Nick Jonas you know
yeah I'm happy about their shows though
the effects I think look a lot better
too yeah I'm actually pretty good in the
in the second one
this is part three this is a part three
yeah we talked about Alan and in the
second one that snake came up to bottom
that's a riff on the bit of when the
alligator bit jack hippo hello yeah so
I'm not a Jumanji welcome to the jungle
when the hippo grabbed him puts a riff
on that whoa and the snake honourably a
real snake we were just at the zoo
that's a whole bunch of snakes says Ian
oh my god that looked that bear had
happened to you to us that was the one
thing I was wondering on the way over
here I was thinking about Jack Black
specifically and I was like are they
gonna be the same exact characters but
I'm excited for the other people in the
ensemble to one thing watching episodes
of Jelinski he's done a number of these
from the set of Jumanji where he would
be gaming with different people so he
did what with like Karen Gillan he
didn't when with hawk with yes I'm
excited for what she's gonna bring to
this I mean she's not a big part of this
trailer but she's friggin hilarious it
looks like they're gonna be going to
opening up a little bit more than
mythology the lure you see them in the
snow you see them in the desert it's
more than just the jungle I thought the
welcome to the jungle was a lot of fun
but I I did feel that there was still
some potential marks that they did not
fully hit I just have faith they'll
probably do it this time around this is
a guy I thought this was a great trailer
cause like maybe now that the first one
did so extraordinarily well they're
gonna have the confidence to go even
further outwards with it I hope that's
the case I feel like this is a story you
can do a whole lot with and get a really
imaginative with it this is a really
great time to release the trailer -
especially with the Hobbes and Shaw
getting so much promotion right yeah
yeah yeah Wayne Johnson Jason Statham
then you flip the script and you get
Danny DeVito and
in tannic love I think the reason why
the the idea specifically of Dwayne
Johnson and Kevin Hart playing off of
Danny Glover and Danny DeVito they can
really sort of channel some of their
mannerisms you know like just their
general personalities are they presented
on screen and there's a lot to work off
of with them because I remember and
welcome to the jungle I don't feel like
they spend time with the young kids
necessarily in order to pick up their
mannerisms or they're kind of just like
doing their own thing based off of like
the jokes and the humor at play whereas
here I think they're gonna embody a
little bit more of that kind of - you
know harkening - when I another
development process like with Freaky
Friday Jamie Lee Curtis and Lindsay
Lohan really studied each other I don't
know they were too good I don't know if
they like really studied each other for
this yeah but I think they can take on a
little bit more than course we're like
the rock is doing some of Danny - that
could see it I could see the Danny
DeVito there you know or some of the
delivery of Kevin Hart I'm like yeah
that's like a Danny Glover kind of
delivery yeah and that's what gets me
excited I guess the one semi bummer is I
feel a little bad for the teen actors
because teen actors they you know like
they're pretty much there to set up to
let our main huge actors have a lot of
fun in the animal and I thought that
maybe they'll get a little bit more of a
chance to shine in some kind of capacity
but looks like they're just gonna be
here again for strictly the bookends of
the film yeah I mean I'm glad they
didn't completely ditch the original
ensemble and all that and I am curious
about how overall they're all gonna play
into the movie and that's one thing too
is I wonder if what the central conflict
here is gonna be because the one thing
they don't really hint at specifically
is if there is a villain or if the
central conflict is just we gotta find
Alex Wolf's character or whatever his
name is and so that's that's a big thing
I'm wondering about because in the first
movie like I liked Bobby karbala but
that was kind of the weakest element to
me was that the movie didn't really have
much in the way of like a memorable
villain other than the stakes and the
just odds of the world yes
so yeah I'm basically wondering now what
the main goal is of this other than I
guess going in and finding him and
preventing him from becoming the new
Alan Parrish this looks like a total
blast I'm excited to check it out guys
it's nice nice and Sony has a good trip
yeah
good on you guys well done just in time
for spider-man what'd you guys think of
this trailer you excited to level up
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification Bell subscribe
buttons are kind of pointless they
matter too
it's a weird and hybrid and Oh Thank You
reg for sponsoring this video hit those
links in the description box and ping
comments save yourself 10%